oh my gosh who is this Wow look look at
this challenger Wow yeah let's do it
also come on play for rating kind of GM
doesn't play us for rating
all right serious stuff d4 alright
alright focus mode come on let's go
let's go let's go come on your name
there alright coffee to the side to the
side serious just going on here I'm
gonna do it I don't know anything want
this f3 thing but I don't know yeah
nope--like what's he do
but hey oh it's old everything's always
a thing let's do this let's do this
where's Caleb Debbie I need help with my
f3 NIMS oh so he's gonna go here and
attack my pond stay he's going here
there's no time one pond I'm gonna
protect it want to do like this sort of
stuff
alright where's he going he's playing c5
so he's playing c5 he's taking my pawn
he's gonna take this thing
no he's doing what's he doing what's he
doing what's he doing get out of here
go come on
inspired choice the f3 names oh by the
way it says the Lama Lord inspire you
help me out I don't don't know these
line quick Caleb get in here come to
work fast
alright now I don't know where need my
stuff goes in this line though that's a
major issue like this might be just
stupid in our doesn't make sense made on
g2 who's getting made on g2 only one
thing attacking it so was he done this
thing's going there I'm just I'm ready
to move take this thing a little more
okay so does this keep up the fast moves
I like your focus and your breathing
they're focused breathing was he done
keep that guy get in there
go do something Knight be useful Oh
Richard serious battle going on no I'm
playing a gym I don't know who it is
either Lanchester one sounds like he's
giving birth to beautiful chess pieces
well if you say that now I can't do my
noise anymore don't undo this maneuver
that's something new where what is black
up to see let's see what you got come on
do some crazy gym stuff let's do it
okay seriously
yeah well those are all my bishop before
no a second ago
yeah boys I didn't see it for ya didn't
see it that was the main problem but I
guess d5 is what I'll pretend I saw the
whole time oh yeah Vasant obviously
stillness still listens to us who is
better
spectator in the shadows I'm doing great
let me just show you guys the proper
technique here that's not a problem no
it's not yeah not a problem
you're up on time yet desperate attempt
okay random move cuz yeah yeah now how
far do I want to go never far oh yeah
yeah oh my god though oh my god I did
not want to get checkmated here they
made this position did they see all this
okay the Joker made on g2 is coming yeah
oh my gosh twice ten hug twice two
people have yeah okay quick first things
first
do not get checkmated here so it's
currently protected but I don't we're
probably gonna like maneuver this guy
around somewhere
alright just a big deal no big deal
let's just really I really don't want to
get checked minutes just worried about
so worried about sacrifices that may
happen at some point oh my God look at
all those nights what's happening what's
wrong with my g2 am I worried about this
no see you whatever he's just right on
the having around it's guys strong he
knows about hopping around I know about
flailing around desperately yeah I know
about making random moose what's the
threat why'd he do that
what'd he do what he did what he do on
the diagonal that he's gonna meet you
remember the square remember the square
remind myself reminder to myself don't
lose on that square oh don't take this
little table the pawn and then my broke
will be hanging in the end oh good
okay just getting just go back
oh these four coins dead mister please
mister quit
come on come on yeah no this fine
bastard is there a night attack my rook
move yeah not really
g2 is not a thing with just yet you got
this yeah you got give me a move huh
repeat we're just come on some ready to
move yeah yeah one time one time one
time come on let's go let's go
eek eeeek there's a strong you guys are
strong
oh you got this Jonathan no no legal
moves prima bald eagles let's go
haha yeah yeah you can speak that
there's not on the GM level that's not
the GM level I know it doesn't matter is
there in commitment yeah there is prima
streamers good game good game
Lanchester one Oh indeed epoch yeah that
was